This is karen's about interviewing rina
parent in this mall on the 5th of may 1993
type to bring up.
Tell me about some of the school stories.
Can you remember anything
particular about going to school.
Well the thing that sticks mostly in
my mind is when we went to my brother
and i mean to you guys school.
My parents couldn't speak english so
obviously they wouldn't take us to school
and i was elderly and my brother
had too much work to do.
Everyone had so much work to do
that we had to go on our own.
So from right up on top was colgan ali
we went down to the jaeger or school.
We went in the school ran and stood
there a part because nobody knew us.
When the bell rang to go in we
marched in with the other kids.
The thing that we had nowhere to sleep.
We just stood in front of the class
when everyone was seated the teacher turned
towards us is no i'm with mr mcnaught
and he said why are you here and
my brother who was older than i
but he was a bit more timid
myself. He didn't say anything.
So i said because my mother sent me.
So then he did say this but it wasn't
a very good introduction to school
but i rather liked school
so i got on all right.
And he was the only one that gave
me the cane and even to this day
when i got back i know what i got it for
what did you get it for where we were
waiting outside. And we
were sitting in stools
and he told us we were to
read a post paragraph each
and i loved reading aloud especially and
the girl next to me just kept on and on
and on and she wouldn't sit down. So i
gave above it got above this and gamertag.
And i don't know if she stumbled or
what but anyway the teacher saw me
and you got me to cut.
And i came up english food on my hand
and i just think i deserved it for
that maybe he had other ideas
but he had read here i might it not read
here i thought i might have made a blue.
What kind of lunches did you take to school.
Don't talk to me about lunches caring.
We had to have homemade
bread. And i hated it.
Everybody had this nice square board bread
and we had home my grade in the
summer it was really delicious.
You could smell it you know cooking
in the winter wasn't so successful
that my mother or my sister used to do it.
She used to make it sort of in a
long bun. And that wasn't square.
I wanted square bread and on top
of that i had to help make it.
What would be to get the used.
And in the beginning i somehow made
the yeast out of the stomach of carbs
or something i never did.
I can't even tell you there might
be other people i can tell you
that if you go along
that we might you might they might it would
be usually used about a flower in the
would be about a hundred pound bags
i think of like a corn bag and
that said it. Sorry. Was it
problem keeping the flour.
Well not so much for us because
we did use a lot. Sort of thing.
Not that i can remember. Anyway.
And then that's the state
and then of course it had to be need
you know you turn it over and over.
So they devised a contraption
which was about a creek.
Or two and a half foot square board.
And then on that it had a stick a
text to it with some bolts in the end
and i was the one that had to go up
and down up and down with the stick.
While the others turned bread into it
and so that's the story about braid
and i just feel completely how
awful i felt taking that brave.
And if we ran out.
Sometimes you know a map.
And this is strange because this is
that reminded me the other day my
elder sister would make patty cakes.
So it would was a to home my bread
or patty cakes. How many lies.
How many lies would they would you
make in a session. Well efficient.
Well i think i don't remember but we
used to make it nearly every day.
So it was always fresh bread.
And now i mean you know fresh bread
being thing wouldn't my word.
I'm tired but would you take with it.
Mostly cheese
or jam i think you know i think within
the medics i think i didn't know about
peanut butter all but you might nosedive.
I suppose it was around that
we didn't know about it.
And another thing i remember from
that same school was in wartime.
I might be jumping ahead of me but
it doesn't matter in during the war.
This was to go school.
You guys school yes.
I would have been about
13 or close on the 14.
And that will destroy sydney
thing italians destroy him.
Both of them our call only
and everyone was so happy
that the teacher gave
us a half of a holiday.
So home i went and i think i can your home
and i think we've got a half day holiday.
I because the save me saying the book
that i'm now quietly only
where you should have seen.
I said don't you know that
that's an italian ship.
And we're all italians on that
and our countrymen. Thanks.
I didn't how i was a
tell you. No i just did.
Yes it must have been a
bit confusing as a child.
Well it was confusing in a way
that our life didn't change at all because
my brother would naturalised therefore
we had a radio all the time and he
had a gun which. Unnatural lives.
People had to put in. And they
also had to give their idea.
But we had this big i think they
used to call it a dual. Right.
It was a big contraption anyway about.
To have a wide but three feet high
and we would be able to catch the transmissions
from either seen so far as i can
remember they're always trying
to listen to news from italy.
I don't know if they've had any.
Say if he if he wasn't a naturalized as it
illegal for him to have that right here.
Yes they would have taken
it off but now that
and the time during this is during the war
you know it's you know i was about 14
then.
Yes i was there any danger you know
that the men in your family be taken
prisoner of war during those years.
Well i suppose there was
always the danger but.
None of our family when my
father was rather elderly.
And they would have to have some evidence
that i had been in the faceted party in
a plea which none of us were my brother
left when he was 18. So it was no
way he could have been but simon.
I just like to say here that the feelings
for the mum motherland was too strong.
At that time.
And you can understand more they would
want to listen to news and even people
that knew that we had the right ear
and i'd ask did you hear any news.
You know it was one thing
that the australians sort of
found him hard to understand.
But if you think that if you
had been in a strange country
and couldn't speak the language. It would
have been nice to hear your own town.
But of course it was warm and.
There was no you didn't hear your parents
be talking about anyone else being
taken this.
Through their formulae were
others but i just probably need
but i just forget the names now.
And maybe sort of you know and i
wouldn't want to be put in any way.
But i remember one one time.
Just to tell you sort of how how hard
things were this is going back a while
when i was about 10. My
mother was very sick.
She had to go to hospital she had
three operations in the one go.
And everyone thought that
she wouldn't make it.
That was the feeling that we had at home.
But i didn't go and say it because i
didn't have a decent drop to put on
and being poor.
But proud
and especially my mother was a very proud
woman she wouldn't want to probably even
see me if i wasn't dressed properly.
But anyway the decision was
made that i didn't go and see
and she didn't like it by the way
i lived not to be nobody to.
What was wrong with her one was the
goldstone one will be in the x
and the other one has come a good form
and out dr. mccabe performed the operation
she'd been to doctors in sydney
and all over the place because she was so
sick and a family had what was wrong and.
She made it and was pretty healthy
after that point with a doctor.
I don't know what he was engaged
to have offices on the corner of.
Ok and mouse with street i think he
was in this and he was in business.
Yes you know he was a. There's
more not a very old up
that i'll manage what he would
have been ideal something on him.
And i remember going in to say my mother.
I'm not like light a time
when she had a bad shoulder.
And she said she said get me up at 3 o'clock
in the morning she said wash mission.
I can get warm again she
said i'm just freezing cold.
All guys do you think they
can do anything about it.
So i made it my business to be there
when dr. mckay come and i said to him.
Doctor i think months said so and
such and he turned to the nurse
and said why do you washer.
That unearthly time.
And she's about doctor she said that's a
routine we wash patients in that time
and he said leave a dirty then and after
that she was washed in the daytime.
So she would have been in the original
base hospital. You know she was in.
Current dangerous think
at the time you know
that was carried out you know current
then and there would also be.
Water away hospital.
Where with a situation.
Are you asking me too much neck area
and i don't know. I think that a fact.
I tried to go past where i
thought the current you know was
and i couldn't find it there was also
the don griles which was originally the
aerosol club which you mother ever in
there may have it was one hospital
but i can't remember going to.
Reno what was it like being the
youngest of such a large family.
Well i didn't i wasn't spoiled to what
you're trying to get out of caring
and i certainly wasn't it wasn't.
Enraged everybody much for anybody.
So nothing nothing me i
mean you can see me.
Sometimes i reckon but i just
grew up going by what up.
Because there just wasn't time sick
when i was young she was very sick
and being the youngest didn't get you
out of doing any chores no no no no my
brother. It was a wonder did that.
He since passed away was killed in
an accident in sydney in the map.
You know he was the one who could get
away with it. I mean i was to stop them.
You know so i mean i didn't
ever call embody me by name.
So i'm used to always get into trouble.
You don't you know decide
but it was a fact.
Anyway so why do you remember
much about your sister.
I know you don't remember about her but do
you know much about you. Sister the nun.
You know i mean very little.
That was told to me she died
when she was 28 in the convent.
What part of the holy where
was she where was she
and i think she was went to rome after she
went into the convent she would be to
bury early age about 17.
And i know my mother had a
big fight a grandfather
and she got an enlarged later on but.
She really never entered into my life and
kind of when did you make your husband.
I mean one of the few dances i went to
rejig there were a lot of bands right.
But i didn't go to many because i
had to be chaperone and my grandma.
Were doing everything but occasionally i
would rather the dance of the jingle.
And i think maybe.
But then you know boys used to call on the
home front row he probably would have
called and hand. Probably would have a
young child there a few young boys around.
And i remember my sister and particularly.
Job because he had a lot of
hair or a lamb and he had a.
Pregame start wars we just play mode
and leave these marks as you
have been back in cama games
but any writing you didn't wear
a lot of hair obsolete remarks.
And so it went on from there
and good name to be oh.
It's your parents
and brought with him he was born in
italy to be in place called bina
and he came out here when
he was 18 years old.
How old were you when you met your husband
when i met him i was probably about 16
and then we started going to get them
and i was 17. Did you where you shop around
for years. You couldn't go anywhere.
And i think we didn't go up.
Mary much really because my
brothers wouldn't come to that and
and finally much eternal and i got
the picture and i might come.
But you know what according to done at
my place but hey if you pay me company.
We talk and everyone got discreetly
debate and we started happening 12.
So you were allowed to be in the same
room on your way as yet we were at that
or even australia day you could
run random it in a central.
You didn't have the elderly member there's
a family following you know to just
discredit instance you know now you know
what i mean you knew you didn't have to go
too far.
So what was life like as a young woman
going into a young girl growing into
womanhood. For my part. It
was rather can i say world.
Because we didn't go anywhere.
We didn't do anything that went any
young people my age at all around.
We need my sister got married four years.
That's a 19. So that
really wasn't very much.
Today why did have a family strike you.
Friends
but we didn't really mix very much at all
in the matter of fact i remember one time
i'd made a sort of a friend.
Where we used to buy
grace rated merengue and
and she would have me to go to the
show with and we'd meet at the show.
But for some reason that i
still kind of an led to me
that i have to go around with
my brothers and sisters.
I don't know what they're
going to do describe right
but anyway it was it was a very lonely
several and a great deal of freedom.
I thought as you know there wasn't a great
deal of freedom and there was no one.
With them and the city
that you could talk to
but i loved reading mostly like
reading who was your favorite author.
I don't have any private all to bugger
up a true love story later here is my
brother. Love story books but they used
to hide under the mattress or anywhere
and i guarantee you know the right man
and i didn't find it so that was all
that i read actually hear a clip from
school or take books from the library
and very now you mention
something about a band slide
earlier. Can you remember i came later
that came later after we were
married about five probably started
a few years early demand
if i go by no place and.
Well after we were married
you have to ask me about me.
Wedding after new and i can married we
want to leave a job. Would you can.
And i have been an apartment
had planted bananas there
and i got a lease which everyone
had to do that they meant.
The land and i got the least grown
up five years with a 10 year option.
I mean the meantime we got married and.
Five years were up so they went
into the lawyer and said you know
that they wanted to get the option to.
For another 10 years and
then the lawyer told them
but the owners of the land
had not signed the option.
And i had no idea of this but i
thought they had a 15 year lease so
that after five years they had to pull
the plan they get a claim i planned.
The plantation and i really
you know run inside a name
but i am still very bitter about it.
Because here the young man and the views
were starting out working very hard
and i didn't sign that option.
None purpose and i might just go after
that i believe the law was brought
in that they could not put your.
Good property unless they boarded
and gave you some compensation
but we didn't we had to leave and
it was a lot of work and i'm top of
that in the very heart of
the family name to ramp.
How many acres were involved in that we
had many and i guess 10 acres of bananas
or two culpability is no doubt
with the magic being here.
It's not a general bug.
And in the meantime we had
to find somewhere else but
that wasn't very bad was the worst part
but also we have to ship the house.
Now this has had already been shifted
once it belong to the sawmill as she
got and i had been his uncle
and other friends say that if i were in
the house is taken down by the board.
I demolished a dorm where.
Transported they train you know the things
you know they talk and board by board.
Yes. And we built it and rebuilt it
not actually demolish you know that.
Anyway that's what happened. I
took it all down and rebuilt it.
Where we were couldn't make.
So when you were on the original 10 acres
there would be but not developed at all.
There was no no no no no no no.
You know none of the
banana growers had them
and they had to build their own houses and
that this would particularly nice
because it belonged to the soil millers
and it was also a line inside in our
feelings which was rather rare in those
behaviors and libya had
painted a very nice
but after about three years i think it was
a nation three years it had to be done
all over again and eventually with it
and least some land i know mr. noble
objective which wasn't very far from where i
was before i was married daughter
actually went to the same school as i did
what was done and when
they were taking it down.
I might there be more in every room so
that the same boards would go in the
same position and i would put up again.
And they did but always with help a friend
and an uncle jack parent who had who
was a big help. So he did you move.
From one land to the next with
a parent or was there a time
that you know we had to land somewhere to
go straight away and we tried we tried
and tried because i think my dad had a few
months for the nana's so we had tried to
find land and that's where we found
that it was very hard because
it was just after the war
and a lot of people still didn't feel
too kindly to return to war to tell you
mr. noble of the peaceful name do you
remember i think it was rain over
and he came from. He was from dubai.
Yes but dubai where we put a grain.
So there was a lovely little stuff that
wasn't in our land but we had rented
that we would have loved
to build a house on.
But he said no he loved us to build it
where we were paying rent for so there was
nothing else we could do
but we put it up there in the meantime we
were living in a tent part of the time
part of the time we started
with libya as an aunty.
So it means really didn't get put up
a grain and we don't have children
and stay here seven you know a little
very hard for a little girl she was two
we did but the house that
got it going painted it.
We planted some bananas.
Yeah but with after.
My husband had come
down from where he was.
We were before and we have to
play a little bit of blame
but then there was more land to
play and i can remember the day
that he started i was the
one that drove the horses
and it was a little bit of a hill and
horses were frisky but hadn't been used.
So i was the one that had to drive them
on the particular violet he wanted
but my daughter to you. Our
daughter had a higher temperature.
I didn't have a moment of it.
It doesn't take a mother doesn't need a
moment to know temperatures so we can run
it. We're going to do if we haven't
had in this land need to be played.
Because you never know
when it's going to rain.
You never know what the weather's
going to do but i'm not around.
Very well and and for.
It's towards the wind and put in the
ground and i've gone sea area every now
and then they have you know going
for you had to help live you know.
So yeah i drove the horses and
he had to play and growing.
Really part because everyone take
pills and you can't handle the player
and the horses he was it's
very hard for one person.
So we planned it and we
got the bananas planted.
And
that would have been about six months
nine months i just forget now writer
that we have cyclone. We used
to have very mixed cyclones and
that is by we haven't seen
any individual anything like
that for a long long time i jes but
we get the side lines from the north
and the wind would blow it would
play havoc with the bananas.
But we sat there with my marrying maps
because the nannies remixed so they couldn't
a lot of damage to them. And it was
early afternoon and we would love.
It was simply having a lot of
rain was pelting down and down
and down towards the river and you
could see your brother. I think.
And there was a family. There is a family.
He would laugh aloud in the house you
know all around he running along coming
but you know.
He couldn't have these cars because you
couldn't get any of the better revival.
But hunch towards the wind
and then we went inside
and we dry we had a cup of coffee. It was.
Labor three o'clock and as
we would making this coffee.
We heard a small thump in the
back of the house and what was
that but we went to the miserly looked out
and we saw some of the landslide
had looked he was about
200 yards up a something
in this club steep hill.
So then with what are we going to do.
Suddenly he said we can't be staying here
he said we'll have to get out so he raced
down under the house and he got the
utility me had a fire utility.
No you've got it out and put it on a ride
and i talked a few things in the bag
and he came back in and me picked
up and shut the doors to me
and just as we were put on the rambam
the biggest landslide came down
and rob just the house.
It just made on it.
And nobody's anything we
just went even thinking
and run in front of me one of the
miranda powers just come up to scratch
and kinda mean i could and
a half eventually settled.
It didn't go right on the ground because
we had a few 40 gallon runs underneath.
So we didn't go right to the
ground but what had been a 10
or 12 stop have we not
stopped down into the mud.
So we got and we just got out would not
be looking fine thing we just went
and i looked back and i saw my
have that i really loved and
that would work so they
were sitting in the mud.
But we read any rain we went over to an
uncle's place put need of millinery farai.
His uncle jack and we
stayed there for the night.
Next morning the cyclone was over.
It's finished. The sun was shining.
So whip up up and we went to law
and we should take the father
of a poor boy to live here
and i think before it happened actually
settled right down the southern side
and the only damage inside was a few
bits of broken couple of modelling lying
around and my wardrobe a problem and
under the bed but had been scratched
or dented anyway. So what to do now.
No good. Jack came again with
the idea of sawing it into.
And he knew somebody at
least to him sent from him
and he knew he had done this before
so this time. Actually saw him too.
I think but the peanut butter is
sorted in two and took it over
and put it on blocks where we have usually
had nodded to me. And once again.
I remember it was winter because
we were living in a tent
and i think members level and going out
and trying in the morning our hands
and the frost on the ground to stay right
in the open because i had to cook for the
men so they had to be a stay there and
we sorted up again in the septic tank
but not.
After all it's raining raining for a long
time so we had never come so used to go
and wash in a little creek
that wasn't very far right we got from this
creek it was all kind of a bit of a you
know i love wedding ring.
I love this time best
i've got there it seems
and the dystopian water on the stimulus
lasted a look for an in a family band.
And so we just write and tell the brain.
There was no buying water in those
days of course you know i know.
Anyway you couldn't face it if you
had he would have thought about it
but decided we have 9000 gallons tank
and the tank had to last
year for everything so that
when it got down to the last time we
used to call the last time it was black.
It was night out about nine of the same as
the roof which would've been about three
feet. It wasn't used for the washing
of bats or anything anymore.
It had to be used just for the kitchen
and had some border had to be
carted with runs somewhere else.
So where would you close. The vault.
Jaeger it wasn't very far away at all.
It was only a couple hundred yards or
something. This little creek when it rose.
But it was in such a position
that we couldn't get to them.
So just move on and.
We went on and on and
were planted in the night
and not long after we had got
the game runs up to bananas was
too low and it got frosted.
So those that work for
nothing in the name.
I'm sure the bananas didn't get but they
would be airing. And it was love job.
To take the bananas in with the slide.
And we have two horses because you
need to force the stop lying.
So one was a required fella
but one by my husband thought he became
the other one lesson. A bit of exercise.
So he put her around the slide.
So i went with the side he was
cutting and putting them on the road
and i was loading. Something that's a
skill that. I don't know. And it took.
And it went through the banana slug going
to pieces in the butt then stop them
at the shed window and they were all
of it in the shape of the mileage
but if any have tried it but
it would be hard to break.
So then we have to go on the fly from
somewhere to get to him it was very hard
in the meantime of course
when we looked georgie boy
and we were all expenses about half a game
and the bubble expensive game to make
a bit of money we planned and beans.
In between the bananas which everybody did
actually because of the nana's running
smells of the brambles already can't
allow it so we planed being there
and get a little bit
of money to carry one.
But many of the time unless we had to
borrow some money to keep going keep going.
And of course when you borrow
you have to pay it back.
That was my militantly.